hey you can see again so this n do come
Connor have you gotten a chance to
interact with any of the fans so far I
had to run out of the Starbucks I went
to Virginia today once again actually
doesn't matter and I went to the gym
yesterday silence yeah I had room
service
I laid down for a second next thing I
know is 45 minutes later accidental naps
are the best so then I go into Starbucks
oh my god guys would be fine I go in I'm
in gym clothes and it's about 60 people
and stars kind of curled in the line
yeah I go everybody kinda turns around I
go I go oh god no the highs and lows of
the celebrity game right I wouldn't put
it that way I just look at comic-con
people this is there's an energy here
yes it's very exciting
people wait all year for this we wait
all your first yeah and I think that you
know in a normal day everything's fine
but like it's comic-con
yeah now we know that this is your
farewell season for a Super Girl how are
you feeling and how are you feeling
knowing that this guy who's been around
forever it's finally going to be saying
goodbye I mean it's really weird to say
nice things yeah I know it's really
weird cuz a lot of my early scenes were
with Mikado you know and one of my
favorite scenes that I've still done was
in that second episode with James and
Nia in his office where she comes out to
him and they kind of bond over you know
we've both faced discrimination because
of who we are because of what we look
like and that was just such a amazing
scene for me to do and it was so I mean
I don't know if you remember the energy
in the room and we did that but it was
something that was so awkward
absolutely
yes oh it's gonna be really weird with
them gone yeah yeah it's it's a it's
turning out to be harder and I thought
yeah and you know I'm
I've never been part of a series that
people have gotten along this well for
this long
not having assistance in reality and
that's always a tough thing to do to
leave but I'm leaving from a place of
strength and courage rather than being
upset about anything so I was like we
tweet we're were the writers and I
wanted the studio that I actors and I
and the crew and I were all in a great
place all all in harmony so it's a very
gracious exit for the character or they
respects his point of view is this is
his worldview yeah and I'm really happy
but though will you be open to coming
back for a guest spots the door is open
for that and we left that door open on
purpose
all right well Cheers all the best here
can't wait to see how it goes down all
right you